LET’S GET RIGHT TO MY OPEN.
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG?
IT’S TIME TO MAKE UP YOUR OWN
MIND.
YOU ARE SIMPLY GOING TO HAVE TO
RELY ON YOURSELF.
EXHIBIT ONE.
YOU CAN’T OPEN YOUR BUSINESS IF
YOU OWN A GYM.
IN FACT YOU RISK ARREST AND LOSS
OF YOUR LICENSE NO MATTER HOW
HARD YOU TRY TO COMPLY WITH THE
RULES, HOW HARD YOU CLEAN THE
FACILITY, HOW MUCH DISTANCE YOU
PUT BETWEEN GYM MEMBERS.
IF YOU WANT A MASS PROTEST, HAVE
AT IT.
GOVERNOR PHIL PURCHASE CITY
EXEMPTED POLITICAL PROTESTS FROM
PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS AND JOINED
THOUSANDS TO PROTEST.
GO FOR IT, IT’S YOUR TIME, BUT
DON’T YOU DARE GO TO WORK.
JUST TODAY GYM OWNERS MADE UP
THEIR OWN MINDS AS TO WHAT WAS
WRONG AND FORCED TO OPEN UP
THEIR GYM THAT HAD BEEN
BARRICADE BY THE STATE.
CONSEQUENCES OF THEIR ACTIONS
ARE YET TO BE SEEN.
EXHIBIT TWO, YOU CANNOT GO TO
CHURCH, SYNAGOGUE OR MOSQUE IN
NUMBERS MORE THAN 50.
BUT MULTIPLY THAT NUMBER AND
BRING 499 OF YOUR FRIENDS TO A
MOVIE THEATER OR SHOW UP IN A
CASINO AND HANG OUT BY
BLACKJACK, HIT THE ROULETTE
WHEEL, THROW SOME CRAPS, SO SAYS
THE UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
THERE IS A CAP ON THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAN ATTEND RELIGION
SERVICES AT 50.
BUT NOT FOR FOR-PROVE IT
COMPANIES LIKE CASINOS AND
THEATERS THAT CAN HAVE 500.
YOU CAN THANK JUSTICE JOHN
ROBERTS FOR JOINING THE LEFT YET
AGAIN AND PRAISE PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S APPOINTEE NEIL GORSUCH
FOR THE DISSENT THAT READS QUOTE
THERE IS NO WORLD IN WHICH THE
CONSTITUTION PERMITS NEVADA TO
FAVOR CEASAR’S PALACE OVER
CALVARY CHAPEL.
MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
EXHIBIT THREE.
YOU CANNOT PROTECT FEDERAL
COURTHOUSES IN THIS COUNTRY,
BECAUSE IF YOU DO YOU ARE A
VIOLENT OCCUPYING FORCE WHO
BRINGS TERROR ON INNOCENT
PROTESTERS.
THE ONES ACTUALLY BOMBING,
BURNING AND DESTROYING THOSE
COURTHOUSES.
IF YOU PROTECT THESE HALLS OF
JUSTICE YOU ARE NOTHING BUT THE
ENEMY BRINGING FEARS TO CITY
STREETS.
SO SAYS OREGON’S MAYOR AND
PORTLAND’S MAYOR.
IF YOU ARE UNTENSION ALLEY
BLINDED AFTER 0 DAYS OF VIOLENT
UPHEESTLES.
VIOLENT -- UPHEAVELES.
THE LAW REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY TO PROTECT
FEDERAL PROPERTY.
FORGET THAT THE NEIGHBORS ARE
PETRIFIED AND HAVEN’T SLEPT IN
60 DAYS.
MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
YOU CANNOT USE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AS A POSSIBLE
THERAPEUTIC IN THE EARLY STAGES
OF THE CORONAVIRUS BECAUSE IT
CAN KILL YOU, AND IT’S AGAINST
THE LAW IN ONE STATE TO USE IT
OFF LABEL.
THE DRUG THAT’S BEEN USED FOR 60
YEARS IS DEMONIZED, AND IN SOME
STATES BANNED FOR USE AS A
TREATMENT BECAUSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP DARED TO MENTION IT.
IN SPITE OF THE FACT THAT SCORES
OF FRONT LINE DOCTORS AND
HEALTHCARE WORKERS CONTINUOUSLY
RECOMMEND ITS BENEFITS ALONG
WITH ZINC AND A Z-PAC
PROPHYLACTICALLY AND IN THE ORAL
STABLES OF THE VIRUS.
OUR OWN DR. MARC SIEGEL
PRESCRIBED IT FOR HIS DAD AND
SAID IT WAS A MIRACLE CURE FOR
HIM.
BUT FOR OTHERS IT MUST BE
OUTLAWED.
EXHIBIT FIVE.
DR. FAUCI, THE HEAD OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES FOR 40 YEARS TOLD US
THE PEOPLE OF THE UNITED STATES
DON’T NEED TO BE WORRIED ABOUT
COVID BECAUSE IT’S NOT A MAIN
THREAT.
WE DON’T NEED A WEAR A MASK.
THEN WE NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
THAT IT’S OKAY TO HUGE ON
TINDER, BUT PLAN TO NEVER SHAKE
HANDS AGAIN.
THAT WE SHOULDN’T USE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE BECAUSE IT’S
INEFFECTIVE, AND CALLS STUDIES
FLAWED THAT SHOW IT IS
EFFECTIVE.
AS A PHYSICIAN RESPONSIBLE FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH SHOULD HE NOT BE
RECEPTIVE TO ALL OBSERVATIONS
MADE BY DOCTORS ON THE FRONT
LINES, NOT JUST CHASE A VACCINE
TO FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS SYMPTOMS
AND COMPLICATIONS AND ARREST THE
PROGRESSION OF A VIRAL DISEASE?
DOES THIS MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
EXHIBIT SIX.
MORE THAN 100 POLICE AGENCIES
HAVE BACKED OUT OF SECURITY FOR
THE MILWAUKEE DNC AFTER THEIR
CIVILIAN OVERSIGHT COMMISSION
DENIED POLICE THE USE OF TEAR
GAS AND PEPPER SPRAY TO MAINTAIN
CROWD CONTROL DURING OUT OF
CONTROL PROTESTS.
MAKE SENSE TO YOU?
FOLKS, WE ARE LIVING IN AN
UPSIDE DOWN WORLD WHERE POLITICS
IS THE DECIDING FACTOR FOR ALL
THINGS.
WORK, PLAY, RELIGION, SAFETY AND
HEALTH.
THIS IS NOT A GOOD PLACE TO BE.
TRUTH AND HONESTY ARE ESSENTIAL.
BUT WHEN CLOUDED BY THE POLITICS
OF LIES, THEY ARE ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND.
YOU HAVE 93 DAYS.
IF YOU LIKE LIVING LIKE THIS,
YOU CAN GET MORE OF THE SAME
WITH THAT GUY HIDING IN THE
BASEMENT BUNKER JOE.
IT’S TIME TO TAKE AMERICA BACK
AND GET IT BACK ON TRACK WITH